Hot Damn Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Walking Dead Episode
5 video.
Not a whole lot happened in this episode,
despite the fact there were some big reveals.
I mean it wasn't a big action episode.
They're kind of holding off for more big super
pack stuff so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet here we go
and real quick reminder new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's a $20 Amazon gift card let's start
with the biggest hot damn Maggie is pregnant
so now Glenn has a reason to come back I think
he is definitely still alive and then they'll
be that moment in the back half with like
I have a son I have a son oh my God I have
to get back so everybody that thinks that
were gonna get this kind of moment like this
moment of realization when the lightbulb goes
on Glenn finds out that he has a son and he
just like freaks out trying to get back to
Maggie tell me there's something more Rick
one about nine months give or take a couple
weeks something more is going to be crawling
out from between Maggie's legs and it might
be named Aaron in Aaron are both good names
for boys and girls on the number for hot damn
Jesse she services this big called action
for most of the other regular safe zone people
people that aren't survivors that are just
like kind of waking up to the reality of what
life is right now we have to fight or we die
and actually like it becomes this big called
action for Denise's character to the gonna
throw into that moment which is like all okay
I can save this guy you really have to credit
terror for little bit about to do with it
like Denise just needs a big confidence boost
in tears there provided I don't necessarily
that they're going to have some sort of lesbian
relationship I think they just can have a
really deep friendship I think at this point
we shouldn't read too much into that kiss
until we see them do something more until
he gets into Glenn Maggie territory I wouldn't
call them in an official relationship you
can totally ship him I'm a huge fan of Merritt
Weaver in the funny thing about Tara's character
is that Alana Masterson the actors the place
Tara is pregnant in real life so we keep making
hiding her stomach behind things that that's
why she sat down that chair that way but right
now like as of this Sunday when I post in
this video she's already had the baby but
they are shooting the back half of the episodes
so Tara on screen is still gonna seem pregnant
for like at least the next several episodes
Lauren Cohan on the other hand is going to
be pregnant on the show but not pregnant in
real life edges is just one of the funny thing
that happens with castes that are really large
on shows that go on for a long time is always
going to be a ton of babies born in real life
in your pregnancy couple babies born on the
show like written into the story but as far
as I know Lauren Cohan isn't actually having
a baby in real life like it just is just something
they wrote as part of this narrative on the
number three though miniport stick versus
many Rick this is actually a relatively positive
arc that I know it seems like they were having
a fight but miniport stick here Jesse's son
really does want to help Carl like he doesn't
want to go out there he just thinks it's too
dangerous and even can probably take care
of her self I think that he does believe she
can take care of herself but he's accepted
the fact that is just too dangerous for them
to go out so he doesn't want Carl to throw
his life away and even better than that he
goes to talk to Rick just just to let them
know what's going on with Carl like all these
over there with Judith he didn't actually
go over the wall so he save but could you
teach me how to shoot that's huge like he
tells Rick yet you are right when you get
really piston me and episode one when I was
wandering around outside thanks for being
hard on me I understand what you're trying
to do is not asking Rick to adopt him or anything
he's just accepting what happened use like
I'm moving forward I understand it was necessary
so is paving a way for something happy to
come out of that storyline between Jesse's
family and Rick's family for speaking of messed
up families on my number two WTF Deanna and
Spencer so this is so messed up Deanna just
completely off the reservation and Spencer
has this really heartfelt speech where he
inspires everyone to just put the food back
please let's not make things go to ship faster
than they need to she comes out of her funk
she starts planning for a way to defend the
save zone it's really positive but then she
catches them being a complete douche bag but
I figure if only one person stole no one saw
wouldn't be a big deal I feel like they're
setting Spencer up to do something terrible
you can have some huge dirt pennies gonna
wind up dead that's what I feel that crackers
sleep moment was at the end like Rosita tries
to comfort them is a hey whatever you're doing
just keep doing it is totally working and
then he pulls the crackers sleep out if you
like that was meant to be ominous and it finally
on my number one WTF moment Denise bangs on
the fence is an act of defiance but we also
see the walls are bleeding a little bit meaning
that it's not invincible the walls will come
down it is certain point that they won't hold
forever and I'll just have to wait to find
out what happened to Abraham clan Daryl I
think next week sepsis can address what's
going on with them and I do think the show
is doing hilltops so they might start running
into some new characters were getting really
close to the midseason finale there has to
be some big conflict and I'm actually I'm
curious to see how long they stretch out the
super pack storyline like if this goes all
the way the midseason finale because as of
right now you have the crazy wolf that Morgan
is keeping locked up he's gonna get out at
some point that thou pry be part of the midseason
finale WTF for something leading up into it
you have to super pack that is slowly making
the walls bleed all over the place and then
you have everybody inside that is like slowly
breaking down mentally thousands you really
good quote that Rick had early in the episode
the biggest danger isn't so much the wall
coming down the wall a strong it's everyone
inside breaking down mentally so there couple
shining rays of hope we have Glenn and Maggie's
child we have Tara and Denise and then we
have Rick and Jesse and I know Carrol wasn't
in this episode but we did see a plate of
cookies even though it's it's not the same
thing when they're not being used as a threat
cookies will never be the same after the second
half of season five so here's my big question
for you guys out of the other big people that
they mentioned in the episode they're stuck
other Daryl Sasha and Abraham do you think
that all of them will make it back I feel
like Daryl is pretty safe Abraham could totally
go that the show could lose him and I feel
like it wouldn't completely break things Sasha
is kind of on a comic book Andrea arc so I
feel like they're trying to build that character
ups I don't need the sauce is gonna die so
run if I had to pick someone that they can
kill the season of like a big member of the
group it would be Abraham because he is starting
to feel kind of overpowered and it looks like
he kinda wants to die a little bit like you
got that crazy energy like when he was talking
to Sasha you doing this because you want to
die you just let me know if you agree that
like do you think that Abraham is gonna die
during season six are you can go make it to
season seven I just feel of all the group
members you could lose you know without the
integrity of the group completely being destroyed
Abraham is one of those people so if the show
needs another WTF in the back half Abraham
would be a good sacrifice to make it all totally
offer my condolences to all the re-shown shippers
out there I'd I know everyone wants to see
Rick with Michelle just because he's with
Jesse now it doesn't mean that it will never
happen the TV show is actually expanded Jesse's
part incredibly from the comic hurt her part
in the comic book is way smaller but I will
say congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner seal of approval what an awesome avatar
you and a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back and my channels
and get your contact info was can happen next
is I still love the game of thrones video
to do their some new Star Wars footage that
icon want to do a video for hopefully I'll
get that all out and still had time to do
golf and like I don't have to delay videos
like I did last week so just stay tuned on
twitter and Facebook I'll post updates throughout
the day tomorrow white as way for that stuff
to post you can click here for last week's
episode of The Walking Dead and you can click
here for the flash trailer that I just posted
all kinds of zoom stuff happening thank you
so much for watching, everybody high five
and I'll see you tomorrow!